Squid Game is
the South Korean thriller
taking the world by storm
and,
if you're anything like us,
you've consumed the
whole series as hungrily as
the contestants licking
that tasty honeycomb candy.
Now that you've survived
all six games,
you're probably left
with many questions.
Thankfully,
you don't have to risk
sneaking into a top secret
island to get answers,
as we've got you covered.
Beware of spoilers
and let the games begin.
Is Squid Game based on
a book?
With its shocking twists
and iconic uniforms,
you might think the story
was pulled from a book
or manga, but it's not.
It's the
entirely fictional creation
of writer-director
Hwang Dong-hyuk,
who actually wrote the story
way back in 2008.
He told Variety
that he did take inspiration
from Japanese comics
and animation,
saying that he spent
a long time reading manga
like Battle Royale
and Liar Game
and wondering
what it would be like
to take part in those
deadly challenges himself.
However, where those stories
had complex rules,
he wanted to base Squid Game
on childhood games instead
and, because of that,
well, we'll never look at
marbles the same way again.
Who stars in Squid Game?
While the cast
of the show are
well-known in South Korea,
many international viewers
are asking:
who stars in Squid Game?
Our down on his luck hero,
Seong Gi-hun,
is played by TV and
film veteran Lee Jung-jae,
who is best known here
for his roles in New World
and Il Mare,
which was remade
as the Sandra Bullock
and Keanu Reeves time travel
romance The Lake House.
Park Hae-soo plays
the duplicitous
financial investor
Cho Sang-woo
insert your own boos
and hisses here.
You can see Park
in Prison Playbook
and he's due to appear in
the Korean remake
of Money Heist,
where he'll play Berlin.
He must be drawn to projects
with red jumpsuits.
Amazingly, Hoyeon Jung,
who plays North Korean
defector Kang Sae-byeok
makes her acting debut
in Squid Game.
The former model is really
jumping into the deep end
with
these intense death games.
And ageing contestant
Oh Il-nam
is played by Oh Yeong-su,
best known for his role
as a monk
in Spring, Summer, Fall,
Winter… and Spring.
We made a pinkie promise
to be each other's gganbu.
Is Squid Game a real game
in Korea?
And, by this,
we mean the playground game,
not the whole locking
456 people
in a battle to the death.
Happily,
this bit isn't real,
but the childhood pastime
that is played in
the show's opening moments
and in the final episode
definitely is.
Squid Game involves a team
of defenders trying to stop
a team of attackers from
reaching a square
in the outline of a squid
drawn on the floor,
with the attackers
stuck on one leg
until they cross
the middle of the squid.
The game was popular
in the 1970s and 80s
and is one of director
Hwang Dong-hyuk's favourites
from his playground days.
He told the Korea Herald
that it is:
"a perfect metaphor
of our
highly competitive society".
In the real life version,
people aren't allowed to
use knives,
but then real life
tug of war isn't played
above a giant pit, either.
As with
so many childhood games,
rules vary from kid to kid
and different groups have
different names
for different rituals.
The secret inspector.
For whatever reason,
we called that
the secret inspector.
But, with the success
of the show,
expect squid game
to be flooding
international playgrounds
soon.
Is the honeycomb game real?
Easily the most delicious
challenge in Squid Game,
it's not like
the cafeteria food is
much to write home about.
The honeycomb game is,
indeed,
based on
another Korean pastime.
Known as dalgona candy,
the snack is
traditionally made
from sugar and baking soda
and has an image
pressed into it
with a biscuit cutter.
Children then
attempt to nibble
around the edges
of the picture
to cut it
without breaking it.
Again, Squid Game adds
a sinister punishment
for snapping the image,
but the basics
of the challenge
are true to real life.
So, top tip:
if you ever find yourself in
a South Korean playground,
pick the simplest image
possible.
How much is
46.5 billion won?
Now for the
million dollar question
or, rather, the
45.6 billion won question:
how much is
45.6 billion won worth?
That's the prize
up for grabs
if you manage to survive
all six of the death games
and walk away the victor.
It sounds like
a life-changing amount
and it certainly is.
At today's rates,
it equals $38.6 million
or £28.2 million.
There are 456 players
in the survival game
and each death adds
100 million won
to the piggybank.
That makes the price
of a human life
$84,000 or £62,000.
Just after one game
of red light, green light,
the prize money sits
at 25.5 billion won,
$21.5 million
or £15.9 million.
Suddenly, you understand
why so many people voted to
stay in the game after
that harrowing first round.
The most important thing is
you get the prize money
on a credit card
rather than
heaving the pig home.
What do the business card
symbols mean?
Circles, triangles
and squares
appear everywhere
in Squid Game.
And, no,
they aren't a sneaky advert
for PlayStation.
Found on the business cards
used to lure players
into the game,
the circle, triangle
and square
are letters of Hangul,
the Korean alphabet.
The circle represents "O",
the triangle forms
part of the letter "J"
an the square stands for
an "M".
Taken together,
they read "OJM",
which form part of the
Korean name for Squid Game,
Ojingeo Geim.
They also double up
as shapes
taken from the floor pattern
used to play squid game
itself.
What is the red light,
green light doll based on?
In a series full of
instantly iconic characters
and settings,
none made
the same impact on us
as the creepy robotic doll.
-Hey.
-What?
-Look over there.
-What is that?
It looks really freaky.
Damn, that thing has
a freaking huge head.
In the show,
the doll controls red light,
green light,
spotting any contestants
who move after the song
and dooming them
to a terrible fate.
But, incredibly,
this terrifying statue
wasn't built for Squid Game.
It exists in real life.
The doll belongs to
a horse carriage museum
called Macha Land
found in
the South Korean village
in Jincheon county.
At the museum,
she serves
the slightly less scary role
of welcoming visitors
to the museum,
so feel free
to move all you like.
Is Squid Game dubbed?
Made in South Korea,
you can enjoy Squid Game
in the original Korean
with subtitles or with
an English language dub.
But, I'm afraid that
whichever version
you listen to,
the show is
no less heart-breaking.
Thank you.
You made all this
a good experience.
Will there be a second
season of Squid Game?
Well,
we don't know that yet,
but there's certainly room
for more stories to be told.
Until we find out more,
we'll just keep re-watching
episode six
and crying ourselves
to sleep.
Did you enjoy Squid Game?
And, if you were running
the contest,
which playground games would
you turn into challenges
for the contestants?
Share your most devious
thoughts in the comments
and remember to subscribe to
Still Watching Netflix
right now for more videos
about your favourite shows
and movies.